i just saw this the other day just came
to my attention on amazon
do you know that on amazon you can shop
by
the identity
the political identities of
the business owners
what i mean by that is if you go on
amazon right now you can type in black
owned business just type it right into
the search bar and a big banner will
come up and it will say shop at
businesses owned by black people now
what does this mean i don't know does
this mean that black people need to own
a 50
51 maybe or 50 plus one vote stake in
the business what about what if it's 49
owned by white people but 51 owned by
black people is it still a black-owned
business i don't know maybe you can go
to the amazon shop by category page and
see they've got links for black owned
businesses they've got links for
women-owned businesses so i was looking
through i said okay this is very very
woke uh what happens if i want to shop
at uh straight white guy owned
businesses i don't look i don't have any
particular
impulse to shop at straight like i own
businesses but what if i did
this is the new rule you're allowed to
to pick where you're gonna shop based on
the identity of the owner okay do to do
so i type it in and you'll be shocked to
find out it doesn't come up
then you look on the page the shop by
category page it's nowhere to be found
because that would be racist despite
what you might be seeing in the
establishment media and the corporate
press right now
everything is not tickety-boo actually
prices are all over the place inflation
is going up the economy is really in
shambles good way to hedge your
investments against economic craziness
is to invest in physical precious metals
now i know you're thinking michael all
right i don't got it like that i don't i
don't have the kind of money in my couch
cushions to invest in physical gold what
if i told you you can do it for 30
dollars per month michael you lie calm
down calm down i don't lie acre gold has
figured out this ingenious way to invest
in physical gold without coming out of
pocket all at once you can do it for as
little as 30 bucks a month you can also
get their 100 a month subscription to a
five grand gold bar if you want to up
the ante but whatever you want to do you
subscribe when your gold stash reaches
the price of their gold bars they will
discreetly ship acre gold to your door
make sure you check this out today you
can do it by going to get acre gold dot
com slash knowles start investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url uh because acre is giving away
a gold bar to qualify for the giveaway
tweet or post why you should be the
recipient and mention at get underscore
acre go check it out right now
getacreglol.com
and thank you acre gold for supporting
the show if you go to a
white-owned business page that's racist
if you go to a black-owned business page
very not racist anti-racist actually if
you go to a man-owned
business page sexist woman-owned
business page
not sexist
of course that is incoherent either they
both are racist or neither is racist
either they both are sexist or neither
is sexist and what it leads to is
something that we've seen
increasingly which is an official policy
of that much-maligned straight white guy
as the worst type of person who has ever
existed
of
of white people in particular but with
some other groups as well officially as
second-class citizens and with men
officially as second-class citizens the
clearest place of course to see this is
at university admissions which is that
if you are
a white guy or an asian guy for some
reason you will be disadvantaged you
will be put in
in a lower category if you're applying
to university than if you're a black
person or an hispanic person
if you're a man you will be put in a
lower especially if you're a straight
guy you'll be put in a lower category
you will be disadvantaged than if you
are a woman or you can claim some other
kind of victim status but that that is a
social hierarchy there you are saying
certain people are going to get certain
things and this this process that we are
in right now this radical social
transformation is accelerating that
we're all guilty of it but when you shop
at places like amazon you are
accelerating that trend now what is the
answer is the answer just never to shop
at amazon i don't even think that's
really feasible amazon just has too much
power so i don't think we need to say
let's go knock down amazon or never shop
there again but what we need to do is
wield political power to stop this stuff
because i don't want to live in a world
where we are defined by these radical
social sexual and racial
hierarchies
i'm so glad that you liked that show
make sure you subscribe to the michael
knowles show here on youtube ring that
bell but also maybe more importantly
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch your google play
and type in the michael knowles show and
click subscribe and that's it and then
you'll get the full unvarnished opinion
that hopefully doesn't get censored like
some places we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you